ん
[音楽]
はいこんにちはああ
慶應義塾大学のマイロと言いますよろしくお願い致しますあの東京から来ました
あの新富町にはですねもう2年ぐらいもっと前ですかねあの3ヶ月に1回ぐらい幸せな
起業家育成ですとか
約役場をもっと幸せにみたいなことをしするためによく来ています
宜しくお願いします
ご紹介いただきましたように私は幸せの研究をしていますここにウェルビーイングって
書いてありますけどまぁウェルビーイングの研究です
幸せというとハッピーじゃないかはぴな知らないかと思えるかもしれませんが
専門家の間ではこのウェルビーイングという言葉が使われます
マーケ覚えて帰ってください
あのウェルビーイングという言葉をご存じですかね
辞書で調べると健康を幸せ福祉っていうふうに出てきます
健康と幸せと福祉が同じ言葉だというのはちょっと意外かもしれませんけども
ウェルビーもこの子を見るとわかります
4基あり方良好な状態
これがウェルビーイングなんですね
健康とは身体が良いあり方であることですよね
ですから健康はベルギーん
幸せとは
心が良い状態であることですね幸せというニュアンスと心のいい状態というとちょっと
なんかニュアンスの違うようですが
専門家の間では幸せのこともウェルビーイングと言いますあれが福祉というのも社会を
より良い状態にすることですよね
ですからウェルビーイングというのは実は健康を幸せ福祉福利
ということを含むきれいな家
欲しい言葉だというふうに私は思います
私は特にこのウェルビーイングの中でも幸せ心の幸せ
あるいは心の健康に関する研究っていうのをやっています
みなさん幸せですか幸せですかっていうのは宗教的な通りだって思えるかどうかです
あの私はペンのはウェルビーイングについての心理学をベースとしたさんやつなんです
ねですから今日はですね
このウェルビーン心の幸せっていうのはどうすれば得られるのかということについて皆
さん
理解して頂いてこれからどうすれば幸せ
になっていくかということを考えていただければと思います
今日先ほどを2人発表がありましたけど2人ともですねやっぱり
独自の新しいことにチャレンジしていてそして地域とつながっていて
ああ
幸せの条件を満たしている方だなと思いながら見てましたその幸せの条件ついてこれ
からお話したいと思います
幸せの条件についてお話しする前にえっと
まあいろんな研究あるんですよまずは知っておいて頂きたい研究が色々あって
例えば幸せな人は不幸せな人よりも7年から10年長寿であるという研究があります
いかがですか
幸せだと長生きできる
あるいはエガーを作ると幸せになるて研究もありますよね口角を上げると幸福度が
上がり
実は免疫力も上がるんですよ免疫力も上がるからだから健康になって長寿になるんです
よ
あるいは幸せな社員は不幸せな社員よりも創造性が3倍高いという研究があります
創造性3倍ですよ
すごいと思いませんかですか皆さん仕事をですねやりがいをもって幸せに働いていると
創造性3倍
先ほどを2人みたいに新しいことをどんどん生み出していくみたいなそういう創造性に
つながるということがわかっています
あるいは
幸せな社員は不幸せなさんよりも生産性が1.3倍高いという間と思います
これも凄いですね生産性1.3倍皆さん仕事が10時間かかってた仕事が7時間で
終わるくらいそれぐらい個生産性もあるわけですから
なんて幸せというのはみなさん目指すべきものかということを私は痛感しています
皆さん健康に気をつけています
健康も夜紅ん
健康には気をつけています
健康に気をつけるのと同じようにまあ幸せも気をつけるべきなんですよね
みなさん幸せに気をつけてますか
笑ってますよね幸せに気を付けるって言葉おかしいじゃないか
しあわせっていうのは
何かの結果得られるものだからまあ神の瞬間に幸せな人生だったなあと思えればいいん
だよ
だから幸せなんて目指すもんじゃないんだよっていう人が結構いますでも私幸せウェル
ビーイングの研究者としてシェアは背がめざせる者だというふうに思っています
なぜならまあ映画を作ると幸せになるあるいは
人とまぁこれからお話しますけど人との触れ合いが
豊富であるつまりいろんな人と接していると実は幸福度が上がるということも
エビデンスがあるんですね
つまり幸せっていうのは目指さないでいて
まあ幸せになればラッキー慣れないとアンラッキーってもんじゃなくてちゃんと
学術的にこうすれば目指せるこうすると逆に不幸せになってしまうということがわかっ
ている
それをこれからお伝えしたいと思っています
これが幸せについて今日お伝えする4つの飲酒ということで
あの知っている方もおられるかもしれませんけども
これは何かというと幸せについての研究というのは世界中にたくさんあるんですね
世界中で何千人という研究者が幸せについて研究しています
幸せに影響する心の在りを例えば自己肯定感が高いとか
リーダー的であるとか感謝をするとか楽観的であるとかいろんなことが幸せに影響
するってことはわかっています
100も200も分かっていますねそこで私がやったことというのは幸せに影響すると
いうことがわかってる100ぐらいのアンケート日本人1500人に行ってその結果を
因子分析という手法で分析したんですその結果
この4つの因子というのが得られますまあたまたまこうよつばのクローバーみたいに
なってるんで
幸せの四つ葉のクローバーと同じだなと思って覚えて頂ければと思うんですけども
これからお伝えしますのでぜひこれを満たしてですね皆さんも幸せになっていただき
たいなと思います
一つ目は何か
一つ目行ってみよう因子といって
何かいきいきわくわくとやってる人は幸せです
この逆はやらされ感とかやりたくないですね皆さん仕事
わくわくいきいきやってますかそれでもやらされ感でやりたくないのにやってるって
言うか
あるいは私生活の趣味とかボランティア活動とか地域活動
よしやるぞと思ってやってますかそれとも
たくないけど
これはもうエビデンスがありますやっぱりやってみようと思ってる人は
豊富では違いです一方やっぱりやらされ感とかやりたくないという風に
まあ仕事もまあライフワークもですねやってる人は幸福度が下がるんですね
からまず一つ目には
何かやりがいを見つけること
何か本当にイキイキワクワクとやりがい生きがい
そういうものを見つけている人は幸せですそれが見つかっていない人は残念ながら幸福
度は低いですね
そう言っても私はまだ見つかっていません自分が本当にやりたい事って見つかってい
ませんという人おられると思います
そういう人は
やっぱりいろんなことをやってみることも800行ってみよう石なんですちっちゃくて
もいいから何かトライすることこれが幸せの為に大丈夫もさっきもチャレンジって財布
スライドにありましたけどほんとちっちゃくていいです
あの今日はちょっとちっちゃいチャレンジをするかそれとも家でごろごろ寝てようか
疲れてるからゴロゴロにしようかちっちゃいチャレンジしようか
迷うことありますよねまあ今日は
ゴロゴロにするか
もし迷ったらちっちゃいチャレンジでいいからチャレンジしてください
チャレンジをすると成功したり失敗したりします
成功したり失敗したりするってことはそれによって自分は成長しているということです
ね失敗ももちろんさっきもありましたけど
失敗するということは自分がこれをやったら失敗するということがわかるわけですから
まあトータルで見ると成長ですよね
この行ってみよう西に関係するのは成長するってことです人が成長すると幸せになり
ます
ですから勉強とか学びとか新しいことを
考えることが好きな人は幸福度が高くや勉強とか学びとかこういうとこで何か新しい
ことを得るとかいうことには興味がないんだよって人は幸福度低いっていうことも
わかってるんですよですからまあ今日ここに来られている方がまさに新しいことを知り
たいと思ってくれてるので効果が高いんじゃないかと思います
二つ目
二つ目はですねありがとう因子
感謝をする人は幸せですあまり感謝をしないで
例えば何か成し遂げたとしましょう俺があったんど威張ってる人それからこれを
成し遂げたのホント皆さんのおかげですありがとうございますって言う人どっちが良い
人ですかね
後者のほうがなんかいい人っぽいですけど実は幸福度も感謝をする人の方が幸せなん
です
それから利他的な人は幸せです人のために何かをしたいと思う思いやりとか親切さと
借りたせい
これがある人は幸せで
逆に利己的で自分勝手で自分のことばっかり考えてる人は幸福度が低いということが
わかっています
自分勝手な人ってなんかシェアそうな気がしますよねあの人は買ってで幸せでいいね
ってよく言いますけど本当は幸せじゃないですまあこの行ってみよう西は高いかもしれ
ないですね俺は俺がやるぜ
でも結局感謝とか人とのつながりというのは希薄になるとまぁ孤立しちゃいますから
幸福度は下がっちゃう
この2つ目のありがとう ac に関係するのはへ
友達の数
友達の数が少ない人よりも多い人の方が幸せです
孤独が非常に幸せに反比例しますですから
もし一人ぼっちになる人がいたらぜひちょっとだだけでもいいから話しかけたり何か
一緒に行ったりして
ポリスというのをなくすっていうことが地域であるいは
職場でやるべきことなんですねですからね
友達は少ないより多い方が幸せです
ただうちの学生であるともっと面白い研究があって友だちかの数は少ないより多い方が
いいんですけどもそれよりも友達が多様なことのほうが幸せに影響するという研究結果
がです
やたら友達を増やすんじゃなくてまあ0が良くないですですから認可校
親友もいるし弱いつながりの人もいるけれどもそういう人が多様であること
自分は何か御気の合う人とばかり付き合ってあんまりこうたような人とは付き合うのは
苦手だという方がおられますけどそういう方はやっぱりコープ度はちょっと下がっ
ちゃうんですね
ですから弱い紐帯と言います弱いつながりでもいいから
たような人とこうなんですかねぇ
縦横無尽につながっていることこれが実は地域を強くし個人を強くし社会を強くする
あるいは職場を強くするということです
ですからこの
つながり
多様なつながりそして利他性そして感謝
こういう関係性が豊かであることこれが
幸せに寄与する二つ目の因子です
3つ目は何でしょうか
3つ目はですねなんとかなる因子
前向きで楽観的で
まぁちょっとしたことはなんとかなるよと思う人は幸せです
チャレンジ精神ですよ
あるいはリスクテークと言いますねリスクをとってちょっと失敗するかもしれないけど
やってみよう
行ってみようこっちですけどやってみようと思えるそれにはやっぱりなんとかなると
いう思いがある人は幸せ
逆に石橋を叩いて渡る医師が場所をただ行ったけどやっぱりやめとぼうかなぁって言う
人がいます
こういう人たちは幸福度が下がりますですからぜひ
何かこれもそうですね何かチャレンジしてみようかそれとも
やめとこを買って迷ったときにはぜひちっちゃくてもいいからチャレンジをしてみて
くださいそうすると幸福度が上がります
そして4つ目
爪はありのままにし昔はあなたらしく因子とも言ってたんですけど
自分と他人をあまり比べすぎない人は幸せです
自分と他人を比べてしまうと実は勝ってもですね
他人に打ち勝って金もの地位を得たりしてもまあその幸せってのは長続きしないという
ことわかったんですよ
ですから他人と比べて勝つというあり方をしていると実は幸福度が下がります
あるいは他人と比べて負けると悔しいし値段じゃいますから幸福度下がりますよね
ですからやっぱり人と人は人自分は自分
自分の個性を磨いて自分らしく
人と自分を比べちゃうことも多少えんですけど比べすぎて
自分なんかダメだ自分なんか特徴がないんだそういう風に思わずにいると幸せです
まあですからこの4つトータルでいうと
やっぱり自分らしさありのままですよね自分らしさを磨くそして何かこう強みを持って
行ってみようと思う
そこに多様な友達がいるとなかなかまがいだからこそ何とかなると思う
4つを満たしている人は幸せなんですん
この4つの因子というのがまあ私が明らかにしたことなんですけど今日もう一つ違う
視点から幸せの条件についてお伝えしたいなと思う
それはですねしあわせっていうのは
俯瞰的なシェア
広い視野と関係してるって事なんです
さっきの楽観線ところでの研究でですね
楽観的な人は幸せで視野が広い
そして
悲観的な人は不幸せで視野が狭いという研究結果があります
ん
どういうことかというとまあ不幸せな時っていうのは悲観的になって何か悩んで行っ
たりしますよね
なんか悩んでいる時っていうのは
その悩みに
意識が集中してしまいます
どうしてこんな失敗しちゃったんだろうどうした
失敗しちゃった
誰誰しもあると思うんですよ失敗した時というのはそのことばかりで頭がいっぱいに
なります
一晩寝てまた明日起きてもああ
あれ失敗しちゃったんで俺あんなことやっちゃったんだろう
こればっかり考えてるときっていうのはやっぱり幸福度が下がります
まただ人間はやっぱりそれを解決しなきゃいけないんでそれ集中してしまうように脳が
できているんですね
つまり不幸せな心の状態というのは何か部分に着目してしまう
一方で幸せな状態というのは
楽観的で全体が見れます
入っちゃったバーはた行っちゃったなぁ
まあいいか
失敗したけどもあそのままほっとくんじゃダメですよ
失敗しちゃったけどここにも解決策あるし相談する人もいるし
この人に謝りいけばいいし俯瞰的に見ると解決策がたくさんあるわけですよ
ですから
幸せな人は俯瞰的に慣れて楽観的になれて
そして実際解決できる解決できると
米子またうまく回ってきますよソースと幸せになってまあそういう好循環が回っていく
ということが言えると思う
一方で正不幸せな状態というのは部分に着目しますもちろんさっきも言いましたように
必要な時は一時は
部分に着目してもいいんですけどもじゃあ自分は部分に着目してるなぁ例えば起こった
ところすっなんであいつあっ怒ってるとき
その起こっている怒りに着目してますけどでも彼の気持ちにもなってみよう
それから我々のビジネス全体で見たら怒ってる場合じゃなくて
やっぱりみんなで話し合って解決すべきじゃないかみたいになると解決できるわけです
から
幸せについて
大事なことというのは俯瞰的な広い視野であですから皆さん
何か悩みがある時にはその悩みについてもっと広い視点から
さっきのアレですよね仲間と共に楽観的に行ってみようと思いながらこう解決という
ことができると幸せになります
そういうわけで
これ最後のスライドなんですけど皆さんにへ是非お伝えしたいことはさっきの4つの石
を満たすように生きること
そして俯瞰的に考えることなんですけど
ついつい皆さんウェルビーングファーストつまり幸せ第一じゃなくてですね
目の前の課題第一になりがちじゃないでしょうか
例えば自分が何か失敗した時ですさっきのなんか失敗するとああしまった
なんで自分はこんなになっちゃったんだろう
でもウェルビーイングファースト自分の幸せと世界の幸せをもし
第一に考えることができたら失敗しちゃったでもやっぱ誤りに行けばいいし
この人と一緒に解決すればいいし世の中って言うんですけどもんじゃないぞ
みんなで力を合わせれば絶対うまくいくはずだそういう発想になると思う
ベルギーのファースト忘れちゃうと
目の前の怒りとか悲しみとか苦しみとか何か部分に捕らわれてしまう
ですからぜひ部分に取られるんじゃなくて囚われてしまう気持ちもわかりますそれを
味わうことも必要ですが味わったら
well being ファースト自分のしあわせって何だろう
みんなの幸せってなんだそのためにはここに囚われてるべきじゃなくて全体を考える
べきじゃないとそれを考えて幸せになっていただきたいと思います今日はご静聴
ありがとうございました
[拍手]